I will analyst estimate Harvey may cost
homeowners as much as forty billion
dollars with a be to repair the damage a
new state insurance law takes effect
tomorrow in Texas it may be another
concern for the victims of the storm the
measure could make it harder to sue
insurance companies for delayed payment
of claims factors congressman Joaquin
Castro encouraged homeowners to file
claims before it becomes law
FEMA tells CBS News it's already
received more than 37,000 claims for the
federal government's National Flood
Insurance Program that number is
expected to rise but a consumer
organization estimates about 80% of the
people impacted by the devastating storm
do not have flood insurance CBS News
business analyst Jill Schlesinger is
here in Jill good morning we talked
about this the other day it's you know
making it tougher for flood victims to
file how is this going to help so this
new rule is really interesting it was
wet it was passed earlier in the year
well before we're in disaster season
basically was designed to curb lawsuits
against insurance companies in the
aftermath of a natural disaster like
this one like this one it also actually
had new rules and modifications to what
would happen if an insurance claim went
to trial so a couple of the pieces of
this that are important we see that a
reduction in compensation to some
lawyers who would represent people who
were suing companies if that claim came
in substantially less than expected so
lawyers may say oh I don't want to take
these cases it's too risky I might not
get paid enough money the other part is
insurance companies paid a fee for
dragging their feet if a claim was in
the court system that fee would be
reduced under this new law ultimately
helping or hurting the consumer here
that I mean consumer advocates are
really against this the the plaintiff
bar from Texas is a strong one so I mean
it's on it's unclear what we do know is
these new rules do not apply to people
who have national flood insurance
coverage so those folks are fine but as
you said that's about 80% of people who
don't have that coverage so how big a
problem do you think it's gonna be so I
think that it's an issue because first
of all those
people who don't have coverage they may
want to sue or have a problem in the
claims process under a normal home
owners or auto policy the bigger issue
for those folks is where will I find
assistance will it be from the Red Cross
we're hearing about these huge donations
will it be from FEMA itself or other
direct assistance from the government
the problem that we've seen in previous
storms whether it's Katrina or in Sandy
a lot of people will say I got some
assistance it wasn't enough or I ended
coming up coming out of this storm with
a ton of debt okay was low-interest debt
but it was debt so are many people and a
lot of the financial planners I talked
to in that area say we are concerned for
the financial stability of the folks who
live in this region and the federal
Flood Insurance Program is already
itself twenty five billion dollars in
debt so is there a pot to really sort of
pull from well the the program has
actually told us that there's a battle I
think one point six or seven billion
dollars left with cash on hand then they
could borrow up to another five point
eight billion dollars or so I think the
limit there is thirty billion dollars I
know that your what you're thinking
which is oh my god this storm is totally
gonna push them to that limit just
remember that that that limit has been
expanded a number of times in the past
we expect that that would be the case
especially with the severity of this
storm Jeff thank you so much